of those dozen workers that have died on
our London transport network one of them
is Amica Nayak he was 36 years old he
was a father of one his mum has been
speaking and she says more should have
been done to protect her son what do you
say to her well firstly my condolences
to Mum Amoco died tragically who worked
for public transport in London
we've lost I'm afraid 14 transfer
workers in London nine bus workers three
worked for air TfL one for the
underground and one of one of our
supplies my condolences to anyone who
lost their life as well I've covered 19
we're doing a number of things to make
sure of public transport safe as
possible we've made sure for example
we're using enhanced clean air regimes
we use an antiviral disinfecting the
sort of stuff used in hospitals to clean
registers during rolls the handles the
bus garage use the restrooms we've also
made sure passengers can't sit near to a
bus driver we've made sure there's a
perspex glass between the bus driver and
a passenger with the protective film in
there as well as you've mentioned we're
also piloting in London we have a way to
come on a bus one door and a way to go
off another door we're piloting on some
routes at the suggestion of the trade
unions who are working incredibly hard
with the bus drivers only land
passengers to come on and off the back
door and not the front door to see
whether that makes a difference the
concern is it could lead to congestion
amongst passengers in the back door but
it's really important I pay tribute to
our trials to work as you've mentioned
on Sky NHS and care workers but transfer
workers at police of fire service those
who strike our shelves are also heroes
during our hour of need
why are we waiting until 9:00 to trial
not opening the front door where the
driver is other cities around the world
have already been doing that why have we
waited until 9:00 one of the few places
that country has got the two doors the
reasons because we
keep social distance and the concern has
been if we have all the passengers going
in and out of the back door they'll be
in very close proximity so actually the
flows coming in the front going out the
back Easy's Alba wish to keep social
distance and the reason why we're not
having a big bang all our buses do this
because the concern is the unintended
consequence of yes although the bus
driver may be away from all the
passengers you know all the passengers
together wrong place and that's not good
yeah but if we're getting on a tube
train for example or getting in on the
same door aren't we generally in in a
carriage and we are all giving it the
2-meter rule are we not so as a result
you know it's up to passengers to keep
that to meeting rule for themselves it's
up to you as the mayor of London to keep
those people who are key workers safe
and that involves keeping the front door
closed my question again is why didn't
we see that to start with which one many
things we would try that door those
doors this week it may not work by the
way I don't want to give the impression
that all the bosses across London will
have just the one door being used we're
trying some routes this week we just the
back door being used it could be the
advice from the bus drivers and others
is it's worth reverting back to back
back to front door on back door off side
I want to pretend all that buses you've
got 9,000 will have just the back door
being used not the case okay so why I
mean bus drivers and train drivers going
to work not knowing you know whether the
same fate is in front of them that we've
seen at least a dozen of their
colleagues face 12 people having died so
far the as level Union has said that
their drivers don't have appropriate PPE
why not well this personal to do my dad
as a bus driver and I spent a lot of
time with transport workers including
the trade unions to do a good job in
relation to personal protective
equipment we've been getting advice and
chasing the advice and re getting the
advice from a major public health
England but the Department for Transport
the Department of Health and the World
Health Organization
and their advice is quite clear only
people who are in care situations should
be using personal protective equipment
so we've been doing is they are making
sure things we need to do to make sure
our public transport is as safe as it
can be so for example we used in British
Transport Police the Met Police and
others to make sure people keep their
distance we're making sure there are
markers on platforms to me is showing
people where two meters are we're making
sure that we notwithstanding the large
numbers of staff absences were in the
maximum number of tubes and buses that
we can fifty-five percent of that tubes
are still running during rush hour and
almost 90 percent of our buses where
continue to make sure the public
transport is there for those that need
it essential critical work as my advice
to anybody else is please please please
don't use public transport leave it for
those who are essential during an hour
of need so why your workers dying
that's about fair okay we've had 14
people have lost their lives tragically
and public transport in London we've had
lots of people losing their lives in
London I'm afraid that bad news is we
have more than 1,700 deaths in our city
it's a tragic for those families who are
grieving and who are bereaved in we'll
have to wait and see what the contact
tracing leads to in relation to the
causes of them catching covered 19 one
of my frustrations for some time has
been not just the lack of testing unlike
other countries we were in a context
raised and so we're not sure how people
coded 19 or I'm sure about is unless we
keep our social distance this virus will
spread faster and more people would die
which is why it's really important even
though the weather may be good this
weekend everyone stays at home unless
you've got a very very good reason to
get food to get medicines exercise once
a day or if you really really really
have to go to work stay